a esto cráneo no se le quiebra la voz
pero no duda en denunciar como varios
soldados rusos abusaron sexualmente de
ella durante horas señalando la de ser
la esposa de un militar española estuvo
allí en donde megabús repas comprendí
que me miraban de reojo salir
rápidamente de la tienda apenas tuve
tiempo de llegar a casa no tuve tiempo
entraron por la puerta de atrás de mí no
tuve tiempo de [__] mi teléfono no tuve
tiempo de hacer nada simplemente en
silencio me empujaron sobre la cama me
aplastaron con la ametralladora
desnudaron automotores
su historia se repite en el marco del
conflicto en ucrania denuncian que están
siendo usadas como arma de guerra por
las tropas rusas la violencia sexual
contra las mujeres niñas y adolescentes
prevalece en todos los conflictos pero
continúa sin tratarse como una táctica
militar human right watch habló con
france24 al respecto fusión rights watch
ha documentado hasta ahora es que
efectivamente se ha sabido de casos de
violencia sexual y de violación sexual
pero hasta ahora parecen ser más
crímenes de oportunidad según el derecho
internacional humanitario' la violación
y la agresión sexual son consideradas
como crímenes de guerra y sus
victimarios pueden ser acusados como tal
las organizaciones humanitarias también
reclaman ayuda inmediata para las
víctimas es muy importante que los
estados entiendan la necesidad de
entregar
emergencia de salud inmediata lo antes
posible a las mujeres que han sufrido
violencia sexual y eso significa no
solamente apoyo
psicosocial psicológico sin duda pero
también anticoncepción de emergencia
a la interrupción de los embarazos
tratamientos de posibles
enfermedades de transmisión sexual con
el conflicto en curso las mujeres están
amenazadas no sólo por la metralla
nuestros cuerpos están siendo usados
como botines de guerra
asqueroso realmente asqueroso no quiero
oír más una herida que tardará años en
cerrar